und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit dem
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten zugleich
CSU-Chef Markus Söder schönen guten
Morgen
schönen guten Morgen nach Berlin Herr
Ministerpräsident die gaspreiskommission
schlägt ja vor nur Unternehmen Hilfen zu
gewähren die die betroffenen Standorte
auch erhalten ansonsten müssten gezahlte
Hilfen zurückgezahlt werden gehen sie
damit gute Idee
das ist ein Teil über das man sicher
diskutieren kann insgesamt reicht es
nicht das kann mir ein Beitrag schon
deutlich raus erstmal finde ich es
falsch dass Industrie und Mittelstand
unterschiedlich behandelt werden Bäcker
und Metzger sind mindestens genauso
energieintensiv in ihrem Umfang wie
große Betriebe die winterlücke die
angesprochen wurde ist zu groß Januar
Februar ist zu schweren zu tiefgreifend
als dass man da sozusagen aussitzen
könnte die Hilfe und was natürlich auch
fehlt ist die Berechnung für den
Dezember die Einmalzahlung bekommen soll
das noch etwas unklar auf welcher Basis
das passiert gerade im Oktober und
November steigen erst die richtigen
Preise viele bekommene Bescheide das
reicht alles nicht aus und wenn ich das
noch ergänzen darf in einem Satz es ist
auch nichts vorgesehen für Öl und
Pellets Heizungen wir bekommen also ein
Heizsystem erster und zweiter Klasse
Deutschland Hilft den Gaskunden das wäre
gut aber Deutschland lässt Öl und
Pelletsheizungen völlig allein und das
ist gerade im ländlichen Raum nach wie
vor eine starke Heizungsform das kann
nicht sein nehmen wir mal einen
Kritikpunkt raus denn auch der
ministerpräsiden aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
also Hendrik wüst angesprochen hat
nämlich das zwar im Dezember gezeigt
wird aber nicht im Januar und Februar
und da hat vorhin die dgb-chefin fahimi
gesagt ja gut aber im Dezember wird die
volle Abschlagszahlung übernommen und
das soll Januar und Februar halt
überbrücken weil es technisch einfacher
umzusetzen ist was genau ist jetzt ihr
Problem daran
müsste das für den gesamten Winter
machen eine der großen Stärken werden
der corona-zeit war dass obwohl es eine
große Bedrängung gab ist eine maximale
Ersatz sein großer Ausgleich gegeben hat
für die Branchen die damals Corona
bedingt erhebliche Schwierigkeiten haben
hier ist es so ein hin und her so ein
bisschen nicht ganz vor und zurück und
deswegen wird es nicht reichen es wird
auch auf Dauer nicht funktionieren weil
viele dann im Januar ein Februar
vielleicht sogar zu machen müssen weil
sie es nicht als Betriebe schaffen und
für die Bürger und Bürger ist es auch
keine echt gute Botschaft nur einmal im
Dezember das zu haben es muss schneller
gehen es muss deutlich effizienter sein
und es muss für alle gelten letztlich
gilt der Grundsatz den damals Mario
Drage gemacht hat whatever it takes das
ist wir müssen durch den Winter kommen
und es bedeutet diese 200 Milliarden
wuchtig einzusetzen und nicht nur
scheibchenweise
ich verstehe einfach schneller machen
möglicherweise auch ohne die notwendigen
Daten die technischen Daten und sagen
jetzt erstmal richtig klotzen und wenn
dann vielleicht ein paar das ausnutzen
oder ein paar Rechnungen nicht richtig
Stimmen egal hauptsache wir helfen habe
ich sie da richtig verstanden
die Hilfe steht an erster Stelle sie
haben natürlich Recht dass durch das
endlose zögern der Bundesregierung und
das viel zu spät der Einsetzen der
Kommission die übrigens sehr gute Arbeit
gemacht hat das sage ich ausführlich
aber ich das viel zu späte einsetzen wir
diesen Zeitdruck haben die Krise war ja
schon länger absehbar das ist übrigens
auch einer der Hauptvorwurf den viele
der Bundesregierung meiner Meinung nach
zurecht machen dass man zu spät diese
Kommission eingesetzt hat und ich bleibe
dabei es fehlt völlig der Bereich Heizöl
und Pellets ein großer Teil der
deutschen Bürger ein großer Teil bekommt
überhaupt keine Unterstützung und dieser
Krise und deswegen finde ich diese Art
von zwei klassenhilfe der
Bundesregierung schlicht und einfach
falsch schon unsozial also ich fasse das
jetzt einfach mal zusammen schneller und
einfach mehr Herr Ministerpräsident
lassen sie uns vielleicht noch mal kurz
über das Bürgergeld sprechen das ist ja
auch ein großer Zankapfel das soll jetzt
nach den Plänen der Ampelkoalition zum
Jahreswechsel das bisherige
Hartz-IV-System ersetzen bei dem
zustimmungspflichtigen Gesetz droht
jetzt die CDU mit einer Blockade ganz
kurz für unsere zusch Zuschauerin die
Eckpunkte erklärt das Bürgergeld sieht
eine Anhebung der Regelsätze vor ein
Einpersonenhaushalt etwa soll dann im
Monat 50 Euro mehr bekommen der
vermittlungsvorrang entfällt das
Jobcenter fördert nun auch
Weiterbildungen und Berufsabschlüsse
Wohnverhältnisse und ein höheres
Schonvermögen bleiben in den ersten zwei
Jahren
unangetastet für einen
vierpersonen-haushalt etwa soll dann das
schon Vermögen wer auch immer so viel
Geld hat auf 150.000 Euro angehoben
werden sie bemängeln cdu/csu dieses
Schonvermögen da sagt die SPD-Chefin das
bleibt keine Zugeständnisse was wäre
denn Kompromiss für Sie dass Sie sagen
okay da gehen wir mit damit das ab
Januar auch wirklich umgesetzt werden
kann
es gibt drei Dinge die diesem Gesetz in
die Grund falsche Richtung gehen erstens
es führt zu sozialen Verwerfungen bei
den Menschen in den unteren
Einkommensgruppen die hart arbeiten
Kassiererin Busfahrer Polizist
Friseurin beispielsweise die in Berlin
oder München sind werden am Ende wenn
sie arbeiten weniger haben als wenn sie
nicht arbeiten seine völlige Umkehr des
Grundsatzes das wer arbeitet muss mehr
haben als der nicht arbeitet zweitens
sie haben es zu Recht angesprochen ist
Schonvermögen für dazu dass Leute mit
einem relativ hohen Vermögen vom Staat
komplett unterstützt werden und andere
die wenig haben hat arbeiten müssen und
da die Leistung zu erbringen und das
dritte was auch wirklich ein falsches
Signal ist dass die motivationsleistung
für diejenigen die gesundheitlich in der
Lage sind die körperliche in der Lage
sind arbeiten zu können weitgehend
reduziert wird ist doch völlig absurd
dass in einem Land wo uns Arbeitskräfte
fehlen nicht einmal die Möglichkeit
bestehen könnte dann jemand zu
motivieren eine Arbeit anzunehmen all
diese drei Dinge sind eine absolut
sozial ungerechte Auswirkung ich besteht
dass die SPD eine Änderung hätte weil
sie immer mit Hartz IV gehadert hat aber
es ist die falsche Richtung des falsche
Signal und deswegen braucht es auch mehr
als nur ein bisschen Kosmetik es braucht
schon eine grundlegende Überarbeitung
die dieses Bürgergeld geht einfach eine
falsche Richtung gut den Kompromiss habe
ich jetzt noch nicht ganz raus gehört
und die ampelargumentiert ja dann können
sich die Menschen besser auf
Weiterbildung und auf Arbeitssuche
konzentrieren würde gerne einen anderen
Punkt herausnehmen den sie gerade
angesprochen haben Arbeit wenn ich das
so zusammenfassen kann soll sich und
muss sich lohnen ist dann nicht der
Umkehrschluss eigentlich muss der
Mindestlohn weiter hochgehen und die
Löhne sind ergo ein bisschen zu niedrig
zum einen ist der Mindestlohn ja schon
deutlich erhöht worden zum anderen
entscheiden er gerade die Tarifparteien
derzeit darüber wie sie die
Lohnanpassung machen in einigen Fällen
gibt es schon Abschlüsse das ist Sache
der Tarifparteien aber der Kernbereich
ist wie sie es zu Recht angesprochen
haben ist es in Deutschland so dass
jemand der arbeitet am Ende mehr hat als
jemand der nicht arbeitet und wenn das
gerade für die Bereiche von Menschen die
ohnehin nicht die höchsten Löhne haben
wenn es nicht mehr Geld da wird ein
völlig falsches Signal gesetzt an die
Leute jeden Tag aufstehen hat arbeiten
und sich am Ende des Tages sogar am
besten nicht vielleicht besser wenn ich
nicht arbeiten würde und deswegen muss
man das einfach eine vernünftige Balance
bringen die Ampel schießt da über und
ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen ich habe
mich total gewundert nicht das SPD und
Grüne dieses linke Gesellschaftsmodell
voranbringen aber dass die FDP als
eigentlich eine bürgerliche
mittelstandspartei dies macht und der
heftige Kritik auch des Mittelstandes
des Handwerks das hat mich überrascht
und zeigt letztlich auch wie die Rolle
der FDP in dieser Regierung ist leider
sagt der CSU-Chef und bayerische
Ministerpräsident Markus Söder danke für
sein und fürs Gespräch